we're not on drugs it's the guest of
honor rickey dillion in honor of all of
us making a video together I wanted to
do something that had a memory and I did
with Tyler which was go through his old
Instagram photos so we'll start here wow
that's a party yeah this is from
February 18th 2013
I will I took a picture in front of a
light Lux is when he started like art
this is when I kicked off my career
where you got not embarrassed by this
one no wait there don't worry I mean
this is better than what I could do when
they had filters come out for the first
time I was like oh my god I am a genius
look the comments are nice like yes I
killed that one yeah here's your next
one I got some modeling shots done today
you have a very expensive wig clothes
are over there I wish I could say I've
outgrown this but I have it I love this
bottom right because you look exactly
like the guy from a show then that's a
character I used to do I like Nicki
Minaj I used to have a little alter ego
Wow flashback okay it's such a baby I
know so young here we go moving on Oh
when I met Shane 2012 yeah my first
VidCon this is your first VidCon and I
stand it in a huge line to wait to meet
Shane doesn't go to conventions anymore
yeah baby found you at the think on to
me I wasn't I guess yeah so like I snuck
him to a party with friend I was
annoying and waiter on a minute before
that does not guarantee don't do that I
know he tweeted like last-minute
meet-and-greet come and I sprinted here
we go this is 2012 throwback pick number
one what is I was showing transformation
the two on the left or from like hi
squad was like 16 probably oh my nose or
whatever this was so 2012 both you just
figure it out in Valencia these puka
shells and then shot the shark over the
beach like the bots and stuff I guess
that was three necklaces immediately put
all three of them on yeah was homecoming
oh and where are these other two
shirtless ones you forgot to wear shirts
when you grow up yeah really like tool
phase like that I think you look
adorable they look like the hottest boy
at church camp yeah yeah that's also the
hottest boy in church can't even read
yeah he's the counselor at church camp
so this is 2012 and this is I thought
all about to outfit booth that one
so Ricardo was in a 12-4 a little bit
first iteration of Destiny's Child and
that was right after VidCon we are all
met for the first time this week when we
decided to make o12 okay so who's that
that's Samuel you look like just boys on
the cul-de-sac about to solve the summer
mystery I was like an Abercrombie &
Fitch commercial yeah this is our class
moving to LA together yeah I was in
Florida with my family a corner flew
down we picked that JC in Texas and we
did it across the country and my tiny
Kia stole all of our stuff I'm humming -
dad look at Conner frit I could get them
erased the bracelet the tongue I was
gonna say myself maybe with Guy Fieri no
I was gonna get off that was a crazy
road trip so we got pulled over that
though he had drugs in the car so they
searched my car it was full of all of
her stuff when we hit a bird which was
sad we broke down a little the desert so
we were like oh we'll get gas eventually
but then nothing ever came and we ran
out of gas in the middle of desert but
it was so scary their phones went to
work and mine barely did like luckily I
was able to call roadside whatever 2012
mirror pic at school haha look at you
I'm in college I was 29 your solar front
facing cameras yeah take the photos in
the mirror like that don't have that
outdated this is no not Halle its Yolo
you so awkward yeah
your shorts make it look every three
points he needs
bad thing yeah yeah okay here's one more
this is one of my poor since we're gonna
pictures ever do something it's my first
one remember we all got to do the
rounded edge yeah unlike there are like
three pixels peeking in your window
through your block go back to Ricky's
Instagram scroll down find it on it
leave a comment making my mo select
photo ever I see you at Connor Franta
like a hardcore like bro phase yeah I
got that a weird like backwards hat
sideways sideways 90s are alive and well
in 2011 hey you want you you committed
to a style know and a we look we've all
look back at all but make sure you guys
go check out everyone's channel here
because we made videos on every single
one of them and they're really fun and I
mean we shot one already that I'm
assuming the rest well they're gonna be
fine
fingers crossed go check this out and go
check out what Ricky's Instagram because
there's a lot of great gems that I don't
even bring on the trip other than that I
don't know do you should make Rocky
Dylan and do like your I don't know like
an altar you go yeah husband fun
Hannah's gonna continue to braid arms
it mild I did speak every every Hannah
to make character where she switch it
out one letter every day yeah
might you guys meet her not hard
kina a great story